FEMALE SPEAKER: American
Himalayan Foundation could not
make it today, but Therese will
be talking about both
organizations and their
great work.
So today is International
Women's Day, which started
back in the early
1900s to promote
civil rights for women.
We've come a really long way
in most respects, but human
rights for women and girls
in some corners of
the world have not.
I'm excited to introduce you
to the work of Community
Partners International and
American Himalayan Foundation.
They're doing amazing things on
the ground to prevent girls
from falling victim in Nepal,
Burma, and Thailand.
Therese Caouette is executive
director at CPI and has worked
with refugees, migrants, and
displaced persons in Southeast
Asia for more than 30 years,
together with community-based
organizations, international
bodies, foundations and
academic institutions.
Please welcome Therese.
[APPLAUSE]
THERESE CAOUETTE:
Hello, thanks.
As Aya said, I've been working
largely in Southeast Asia.
And I worked primarily in the
beginning with refugees and
displaced populations in the
late '70s and early '80s at
the end of the Vietnam War.
And during that time although I
was working with refugees I
found that more and more young
girls and young adults were
finding themselves in very
vulnerable situations outside
of the refugee camps.
But when I started to do
specifically work on
trafficking, I found that most
of the people at that time in
the early '90s or late '80s
were being trafficked to I
think what we--
the image at least I had at the
time, or I think people
still have of trafficking is
people being abducted or
tricked in their village,
brought across borders and put
into brothels.
Very typical brothels where you
have girls locked in and
they have numbers on their chest
1 through 25, and you go
in and you pick which
number you want.
Now we saw that.
That was very typical in the
'80s and early '90s.
But I've seen that it's changed
dramatically in the
last 10, 20 years, and I'd like
to talk about that today
because I feel that a lot of
us have a very different--
including myself-- still have
these other images of
trafficking that are not what
we see on the ground today.
So I'd like to kind of walk
through that and I'd like to
make this presentation more
presentation of a discourse or
discussion about trafficking,
and not me telling you what
trafficking is.
Because I think it's so nuanced
and so complex that
we're all really struggling to
try to understand it and
respond to it.
So I'd like to kind of present
to you the challenges that I
find in my work, and ask you to
kind of think that through
with me as you think about these
issues and what you're
aware of in other contexts.
So I'd like to ask you to maybe
just turn to the person
next to you, or--
because I know we have several
people who are not here with
us physically--
to just think for a minute or
two how you would define
trafficking.
How do you use it, and if you
just turn to two or three
people next to you and just try
to figure out what does it
mean to you.
What words do you use?
How do you use trafficking?
Just take one minute.
I'll just do it real briefly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
OK, let me bring you back.
I want to say that I think if
we took a poll, we'd come up
with a whole bunch of different
images, and I think
this is what I see in my
work all the time.
And I think it's not only
a problem that I face.
I see that the international
community is faced wtih these
same dilemmas.
If you look at the United
Nations today, we have a wide
range of conventions and
treaties and declarations on
trafficking, all of which have
very narrow definitions, and
have reflected that
period of time in
which they were written.
And yet what we find is they
really don't apply today to
the kind of dynamics
that we're finding.
And there's been an effort by
the UN to try to identify some
special repertoires, some
working groups, to try to
explore a broader or more
relevant definition for
trafficking that we can use to
help deal with the issues that
we're faced with.
And yet this is in-process,
and we don't really have a
very clear good working
definition.
And as a result, when you bring
countries together or we
bring non-government
organizations or donors or
communities together,
we're often not
talking the same language.
And I think this is one of the
biggest problems that we face
with trafficking is that we have
all different images, and
when we sit down together
we don't have a way
to talk about it.
At the same time--
over 20 years I think I've been
working on this issue--
I cannot find any communities
or girls who have been
trafficked who identify
themselves as
a trafficked person.
And if you talk to villagers,
"Have you been trafficked?
Has anybody here been
trafficked?" they would say
immediately, "No, not in our
village." But if you ask them
about vulnerabilities and
migration it's a completely
different discussion that
we have that follows.
So I just want to preface our
discussion today that this, I
would argue, is probably the
most important point when you
start to talk about
this issue.
To just explore with one another
what you're actually
talking about and what images
or what dynamics
you're really exploring.
What we see today is that
migration is happening in the
greatest numbers than we've
ever seen in our time.
There's over 250 million people
who are living outside
of their countries.
That doesn't mean that they're
all undocumented.
It certainly doesn't mean that
they're all trafficked, but
they're all moving, and in ways
that we've never actually
had to deal with in our world.
And although both men and women
are traveling and are
moving, women are by far
more vulnerable.
And this is largely because most
of women's work is in the
informal economy.
In markets, in agriculture,
domestic work,
babysitting, day-care.
We see it in our country, you
see it around the world, that
many of the jobs that women
hold are not in the formal
labor sector.
Also much of women's
work is irregular.
Their part-time work, they do
piece work, number of pieces,
in this example, the number
of fish they serve.
It's seasonal.
They aren't often in the
regular economy.
They're often less educated.
Their gender roles are more
defined, and what we find in
developing countries is they
marry much earlier.
They're are also in conflict
situations among refugees.
80% of all refugees, the
millions of refugees in the
world, are largely women
and children.
So women really do make up the
majority of people who are at
risk in the migration context.
Today I'm going to focus on the
work in Burma, and that's
where I spent--
this keeps moving, sorry--
the work in Burma.
And that's where I've worked
for the past 20 years.
Although I've worked in
Southeast Asia as a whole,
Burma by far has had the most
complex and difficult
migration dynamics
in the region.
The reasons for that is that
it's surrounded by the largest
developing countries
in the area.
Thailand, India, China, so
there's a lot of opportunity
outside their borders.
It's an extremely
poor country.
There's been a lot of ethnic
conflict and warfare for the
past 50 years.
And there are enormous ethnic
minority populations around
the country.
There are 36 major ethnic
minority populations and 136
if you count all the minor
ethnic minorities.
The vulnerabilities of ethnic
minority communities--
not speaking the major
languages, not able to access
health services or education
in the countries where they
live, is a big risk factor for
the people who are being
trafficked today.
Let me just jump back to say
although Eileen from the
American Himalayan Foundation
was unable to join us today,
one of the ways that we started
to collaborate in our
work was that we both were on
a panel and we realized that
the discussions and the
presentations we were
providing were almost
identical.
Even though she focuses her work
in Nepal, we could have
used the same case examples,
we could have used the same
presentations, almost
verbatim.
And one of things that I'd like
to leave you with is the
understanding that these
dynamics are really not
country-specific.
It's amazing to me when I go
around to speak, or meet
others, who are working on these
issues the similarities
in Eastern Europe, the
similarities of Iraqi refugees
who are fleeing to Syria and
Jordan as illegal immigrants.
You see these dynamics playing
out all around the world.
And so even though they couldn't
be here today to
present another case example,
I think what I'll be able to
present today will highlight
very closely to what the
reality is they do
on the ground.
So what I'd like to talk a
little bit about is these
current dynamics of trafficking
that I find
happening in the 21st century,
in the past 10 years.
They are so different
from how I started.
In Southeast Asia, these are
just the beginnings of the
infrastructure of the roads that
have been developed in
the last 10 years.
Prior to that, certainly 15
years ago, but for many
countries as early as 10
years ago, all of these
borders were locked.
You couldn't travel
across borders.
And that has fueled not only
migration, but trade, consumer
goods, drug trafficking, a lot
of issues that have emerged in
the region have scaled up
considerably as a result of
all the infrastructure.
But it's not only roads.
It's also cellphones, it's
a lot of infrastructure
electricity.
With that comes access
to the internet.
All of the resources that have
come in the past 10 years have
really changed these communities
dramatically.
AUDIENCE: What are
the black lines?
THERESE CAOUETTE: Say again.
AUDIENCE: What are
the black lines--
THERESE CAOUETTE: The roads.
The new roads that have been
built in the last 10 years are
linked across borders.
And so now as you see
that young people--
their dreams and aspirations
are changing very quickly.
They see the cell phones, they
see the internet, they see the
axis of opportunities.
Even though their absolute
poverty has improved, the
disparity between what they
have in their villages and
what they see in the
cities is dramatic.
And they want to be
a part of it.
They want to travel just like
our kids do, or our friends.
They want the economic
opportunities and security
that they see others
have around them.
And they want to travel.
They want to explore a world
that's bigger than themselves.
They want to move beyond the
gender tradition roles that
they've been told are the norm,
are their expectations.
And they want to do more
in their life.
But they're entering a global
market that is looking for
cheap labor.
They're entering the global
market that's trying to find
the cheapest race to
the bottom for
the cheapest workers.
And they're entering in an
environment where they're
promoting tourism.
Governments are also encouraging
exportation of
labor because by exporting
labor, they're able to deal
with the unemployment or
underemployment in their country.
And they're also able to obtain
foreign exchange.
The amount of remittances
worldwide from people in
developing countries sending
money home is now in 2011
reached $351 billion.
That is more than three times
all of the foreign development
assistance that has gone to
developing countries during
that same period of time.
And it's also almost about the
same amount of money as direct
investment in those countries.
It is an enormous amount of
money and governments are
promoting their nationals
to go abroad to work.
But when they recruit, people in
these villages have no idea
if this is a formal arrangement
organized by the
government, or if this is a
black market agent under the
table who's going to bring
across the border and give
them a real job.
They have no way to understand
who's who.
So in this context, they see
opportunity, they want to go
for it, and they have
no idea to how to
decipher which is which.
So I'd like to tell
you a story.
This is a village
that I worked in
for many, many years.
And I have a daughter who's
now 22, but at the time--
this was about 15 years ago--
we would go frequently to this
village, and she got to know
all of these children
in this village.
And she would often play this
rubber band jump rope game
with these girls and they were
very good at it, and she would
always look forward to it.
So this is a last picture
we had of them
in the fourth grade.
When we came back the next year
she ran off to find the
friends and they were all gone,
because they had all
gone to get a job in the city.
Either in Bangkok, in Kunming,
in China, or over to India.
She was living in Bangkok at the
time and very excited, so
she'd run around to all of the
houses to find out which girls
had gone to Bangkok to get their
addresses or their phone
numbers so she could call
them when she got home.
And that any of the parents had
a number or a contact for
any of their kids.
And this is the hole
that they go into.
And the question I always want
to raise is, are these
children trafficked?
This is the dilemma, and if
we only look at quote
"trafficking," we look
at the end game,
what happened to them.
But this doesn't really solve
the risk, and so somehow I
feel we really need to start to
turn it around and we need
to look at the vulnerabilities
of these kids.
And what do we need to do to
make sure that if they want to
move beyond their village that
they have the skills and the
resources and the knowledge to
be able to do so safely or
with some opportunity for
recourse, or redress, if they
get in a vulnerable situation.
If we just wait to define which
one of these kids are
trafficked, it's kind
of too late.
What we see happening on the
borders where I work in Burma,
is that most of these young
people are looking for jobs.
When they cross the border,
there's one area that I just
went to recently and I've been
going for a number of years,
and the Thai factories are
building their factories right
up along the border, just
like we did with Mexico.
Right up along the border so we
can get very cheap labor,
half the price of
Thai laborers.
And these Burmese young people
come up to the border to work,
and there are about 4,000 or
5,000 who cross the border
every morning, get in trucks,
and go to the factories where
they're sent to work
like day labor.
You can really do anything you
want to these young girls
because they have no
documentation, they have no
rights, they're illegally in
the country, and they're
working under the table.
And in that context, you can not
pay them, you can pay them
the whole amount, you can make
them stay, work all night, not
work the next day, or take them
further into another city
and not let them return.
And they have no way
to negotiate that.
And we see this dynamic
over and over again.
They live in really horrific
conditions and very difficult
labor conditions with very
little protection of
sanitation or the environment
in which they work.
And more and more of these young
girls and the children
of migrant workers are
becoming stateless.
They have no identification.
They have no citizenship.
And so they can't access
health services in any
country, or education.
They will be their whole
life illegal.
And if I did a report today,
or if I really focus what I
think is the most urgent issue,
I would say it's this
growing number of stateless
children.
Migrants having children
abroad.
The children are illegal because
they're not legal in
the country that they're in.
They can't go back, or they're
from ethnic minority
communities that were never
registered in the first place.
And so they never had a
identity, and when they left,
they can't go back with
any identity.
This population is significant
and growing.
And so in the end,
they're illegal.
And they can be deported,
arrested at any point in time,
if the employer doesn't
want to pay them.
If the floods in Thailand,
for example--
now we blame migrants because we
don't have enough jobs, so
we're going round them
up and deport them.
We have a whole dynamics of
these things happening in our
own country.
And so we just round them up
and deport them and that
somehow solves the problem.
And this cycle just continues
like this.
I believe that the real way to
change this is to try to think
about what we can really do to
empower the young girls and
the young children--
youth--
who are migrating.
I think that the typical
responses that we see in our
media and that I was very
involved in the early years--
shelters, prevention, trying to
warn them about the dangers
of migration, rescuing those who
are in the brothels or in
these horrible factories, trying
to help them return,
reintegrate back into
their community.
But what I've learned over the
years that keeps them in the
position of a victim.
It doesn't really help them
with their life goals and
their dreams and their
aspirations for something
beyond the village.
What they really need is some
life skills, some education,
some resources and opportunities
so that they can
actually fulfill their
aspirations to be more than
miring at 14 or 15 years old
and following in their same
traditional patterns that
they've seen their mothers and
generations before them.
They want something else, and
so I think that our typical
responses to trafficking
have to be challenged
and mine have been.
To really emphasize a lot more
working with these communities
and with these young people
who are at risk.
But working with those girls
is on the picture.
About what they want to do about
what their conditions
are in the workforce, what
kind of jobs they want.
Studies, life skills that
they hope to attain.
Otherwise they just have to pray
each time and hope next
time they migrate they'll
have better luck.
And so what we've tried to
focus on more and more is
schools, both formal and
informal schools.
What we've found is a lot of
children don't go to school
when they're young, and so by
the time they're 12, 13, 14
years old, they can't go
to the first grade.
So they've got to start
working with literacy
programs, life skill programs,
other informal courses or
classes that can take place in
the evening, that can work
with illiterate populations and
build them into a program
that reaches and meets
their needs.
There's a big challenge of
trying to get schools to the
remote rural areas, especially
to ethnic minority
populations.
They speak very isolated, small
languages that aren't
very common, and very hard to
find teachers who teach in
those languages.
They are very hard to
get them to stop
working during the daytime.
They've got a lot of
responsibilities to keep the family.
A lot of them are married
very young.
What we find is that we need
to do a lot to actually get
them to school.
What I see happening in some
of the remote areas is that
they're trying to prepare
boarding schools for kids to
come to stay in so that they can
stay Monday through Friday
and not have to walk so far
and actually attend the
schools that are closer to
the cities or the towns.
This one that I just saw
a few weeks ago--
and they set this
up themselves.
But obviously we should be doing
more to support these
kind of efforts by the community
to keep the girls
and young children in school.
And in addition, I find over and
over again people asking
for preschools or
pre-kindergarten programs.
At first I used to keep
thinking, well maybe don't we
need to focus on primary school
first, or literacy first.
And what I've learned is
actually that the preschools
are actually really key to
getting the older siblings
into school, to getting the
parents working and employed
so they don't have to ask their
younger children to work
in their place, to getting
children literate and able to
communicate in the national
language so that when they go
to school they understand the
language and have more
likelihood to succeed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: No, sure.
I just have one more point and
then I'll actually stop.
But this is probably my last,
so I can stop now.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
preschool encourages
adults to get a job.
THERESE CAOUETTE: To work.
When the children go to school,
the mothers are free
to work, or they don't have
to ask the older kids.
The question was, so how does
that help parents be employed?
So we found that preschool and
also alternative schools have
been very important
in the American
Himalayan Foundation also.
Most of us have really focused
the majority of our work on
schools, both formal
and informal.
And that we really need to work
with the aspirations and
the goals of the communities and
those children and young
adults, so that they can
actually migrate, travel,
move, take jobs with some skills
and some knowledge of
their rights.
So I think this is a
very important--
while at the same time
negotiating a environment that
respects their rights.
I think that's the challenge
for us as outside to those
communities.
That we need to understand and
struggle to understand the
ongoing discourse
on trafficking.
How these issues are changing,
how our policy of our
government impacts those
communities and the
opportunities that young
people are offered.
Our multinational corporations,
the policies and
rules that they practice
when they're abroad.
I think there's a number of
considerations that we have to
really be challenged by, and
I'd like to leave you with
these before I give the
microphone to Paula.
I think we have to
be very aware of
how we "other" others.
And I do it all the time, but
we see them somehow as
different from us, and they're
not any different than what my
daughter wants.
She wants to travel, she wants
to see more than I did, she
wants to have a world that's
bigger than Bainbridge Island
up in Washington.
She wants something bigger than
that, and so do these
kids, and we have to
really be careful.
And parents want their children
to stretch beyond
what they know is possible.
Because sometimes I get really
frustrated when I see in the
media and I hear people talking
that somehow parents
sold their kids, or
they minimize it.
And it's really not a very
fair or empathetic
understanding of the context
with which they're trying to
raise their children.
I think we also have to work to
increase our own tolerance
and understanding of cultures
and the different practices.
It's very difficult for me.
Like I said, I was just able
to travel in Burma the last
month, and a lot of girls
are marrying at 14
and 15 years old.
It's very hard to
work with this.
It's hard to see these young
kids, and yet you can't have a
simplistic answer to this
and expect change.
But you really need to
communicate this into the
issues and work with
families and
communities on these issues.
There needs to be basic labor
rights, even for people who
don't have legal status.
We have to do it in our own
country, and we have to do it
around the world.
You can't really be
an illegal person.
You have some basic rights
no matter where you are.
And I think it's important to
recognize and work towards
formalizing women's work--
domestic workers, babysitters,
in the markets.
We have a lot of
informal work--
farm workers--
that is not recognized as formal
labor, even again in
our own country.
And I think we should focus on
this labor exploitation and
not on controlling movements
of people.
Focusing this problem on keeping
people in one place
and not allowing them to move is
what results in this cycle
of deportation and illegal
hidden dynamics that people
can't get out of.
And we have to recognize that
we have large unmet labor
needs, and that we are going
around the world trying to
find cheaper markets.
And that we need to look at how
these practices take place
and how to protect and promote
a fair labor exchange.
I was just in Burma the last
month, and I suppose some of
you may know that the country's
slowly opening up.
And you could not believe how
many multinational companies
are descending in weeks on this
place and trying to set
up their factories.
Because this is 60 million
people with no work, very
cheap labor.
And if we don't have some
mechanisms with which we can
monitor and protect and promote
their rights, then
this cycle only continues
at a even more rapid
pace than we see today.
And I think we need to hear and
work with communities on
the ground to meet
their needs.
As I mentioned earlier, none
of these communities see
themselves or any of the young
people in their communities as
being trafficked.
That discourse is not theirs.
So if we want to really deal
with these issues, we're going
to have to really talk in a
language and listen to the
concerns and the realities that
they perceive in their
communities in order to
change these dynamics.
So I'd like to leave this with
you, with some of the things
that I struggle with
in the field.
And I would like my colleague
Paula Bock, who works very
closely with me, to talk to you
a little bit about what
she does on this end to
complement that work.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
PAULA BOCK: Hi, my name's
Paula Bock and I work on
community communications
and development.
So that's telling the stories
of the people in Burma and
along its borders and helping
to get support.
I want to tell you a little bit
about how I got involved
and then how if you're
interested you can get involved.
So not too long ago I
was a journalist.
I had a long career
as a journalist.
But I also had a secret life.
And that was volunteering with
my husband, who's a doctor, at
a refugee clinic run
by a really amazing
woman refugee doctor.
And while we were there--
this is back in 1996--
we crossed the border from
Thailand in a pickup truck at
night over the hills to
a little village in
rebel-controlled Burma, where
they hadn't seen of
pediatrician in years.
And I fell in love with the
children, playing with them.
And these are two of the
girls, [? Shua ?]
and [? Omoo ?], and all the kids
were really delightful.
These two were good friends in
particular, and in fact they
were in preschool.
So you heard about the
importance of preschools, and
they used to sing
the ABC song.
Anyway, after my year off--
I had taken a sabbatical
for my job--
we came back to Seattle where we
live, and then I found out
that the village had fallen
to the military.
It was just my heart, you know
that something had happened.
So I convinced the newspaper to
send me back on a special
assignment, and I was trying
to find the girls.
I didn't tell the
newspaper that.
I said I was going to write
about the civil war in Burma.
And I couldn't get to them
because there was this war.
But over the years I kept trying
to get contact and I
would hear things.
And as they grew up,
what happened.
Their village was occupied
by enemy soldiers, right?
They were very poor.
One of them was an orphan, so
all of these factors made them
so vulnerable.
And like so many other
girls, so vulnerable.
Would they leave the village
to try to find work?
Would soldiers try to take
advantage of them?
What happened?
So what happened was actually
a really good thing.
After several years they were
both able to get out of the
village and get into
boarding school.
So now they're 20--
around 19, 20-- one wants to
be a teacher and the other
wants to be a doctor.
So it's like oh yeah, that's a
great story, but there are 43
million people like them who
are displaced still.
I mean those are two of 43
million who had a good story,
and so that is why I thought
I've got to do more.
Anyway, so I got more involved
and I was here in America,
what can you do here?
I got involved with a little
group and we did raffles and
all kinds of things like.
That I took ESL courses,
ESL tutoring, and I
went over and I tutored.
I taught aerobics to refugee
medics over there.
And in America went and told
people about Burma.
I wrote about it.
Those happened to be
my skill sets.
You have other skill sets.
So here are 12 ways to get
involved if you're interested.
Share your expertise.
I know a lot of people have
expertise here in technology.
One of our colleagues is doing
really interesting project,
trying to get it off the ground
with using phones,
interactive voice recognition,
to provide health care
information to people
on the move.
So that could be trafficked or
migrant people, many of them
are illiterate, so it's great to
get that information about
malaria and reproductive
health over the phone.
But there's solar-powered
phones, there's a lot
going on with that.
Something simple for you is
setting up and training using
Google Apps and other
Google tools.
At our organization--
and this is both in the
States here and
with our local partners.
I mean, we touch the
Google tools
and use them so clumsily.
So just to have somebody kind
of hold our hand and say, OK
here are your needs, you should
really be using this
and this is how you do it.
SCO optimization,
graphic design--
if there's a website wizard or
goddess who could help, you
know we use Drupal, that
would be great.
And not just with our
organization, but any
organization that does this kind
of thing, share with your
friends, learn about
trafficking
or women and girls.
Whatever your passion is--
Burma, Nepal--
and share that with
your friends.
Host conversations, post, blog,
talk about it, engage
your network.
We have wonderful supporters
and donors
who do a baking book.
They've done crafts things.
It doesn't really matter what it
is, the idea is to engage.
One of our supporters is a
Broadway producer, and she had
a Broadway bash.
So it just depends on your
expertise and your contacts.
Donations are always welcome,
and I know there's an employee
matching gift, so
that's helpful.
Online friend-to-friend
fund raising, we're
starting to do that.
And if you spend a lot of time
online with your communities
online, that might
be something to
get involved with.
And then there's also travel,
to broaden your horizons and
look for volunteer
opportunities.
So thank you very much,
and those are--
FEMALE SPEAKER: And now
questions and answers.
PAULA BOCK: Yep.
THERESE CAOUETTE: People also
listening in want to ask
questions, feel free.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: OK, just let
me repeat it for the people
are listening in.
She was asking why is it that
people don't identify with the
word trafficking?
Is it the experience
of trafficking
itself or just the word?
Is that pretty much--
so I would say that it's
a little bit of both.
They don't have that word, of
course, in their vocabulary,
so that doesn't make sense.
And if you if you translate it,
it doesn't really work.
But they also don't
have the concept.
I mean if anybody have been
fortune of to travel in some
of these really remote areas,
the trust and the kindness,
the generosity is so amazing
that they just don't believe
people would take advantage
of anybody to that extent.
I think they really
fundamentally
don't believe that.
They wouldn't have it
in their world view.
But even when they
face migration--
then I think that there's
another issue.
When it does happen there's so
much shame, especially for the
girls, that when they
come back they would
never talk about it.
So it perpetuates that cycle.
When you talk about
vulnerabilities it's a little
bit less personal.
It happens to everybody
in different contexts.
So people feel a little bit more
comfortable to talk about
the vulnerabilities of other
people, maybe not of
themselves.
But even in that context
I just don't feel that
trafficking, and certainly
the trafficking--
because we ourselves don't even
know what we're talking
when we use that word.
They themselves also are
very confused by it.
But migration is much
more concrete.
People are moving, there are
risks, things happen.
It's much more concrete--
obvious-- to them what
we're talking about.
So it's a combination of the
two, I guess is what I'm
trying to say.
Yes please.
AUDIENCE: I really loved hearing
about [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: Yes.
She's asking about--
education is great, but
then there's a void.
There's a lack of jobs that
people face when they actually
do finish school, or
become literate.
And I think that's very
much a reality.
I think the whole effort to do
livelihoods and try to work
with women and find other
alternative to employment is
very critical.
And I think that there are
opportunities, people are
working on it.
The infrastructure
of the new roads.
These are the positive
things of that.
It's bringing more jobs.
It's bringing a way to
sell their produce.
It's bringing markets.
You see people in remote areas
on this last trip sewing
handbags, things that they
can sell in the market.
That wasn't there before.
So the development of the
infrastructure isn't only bad,
it just brings new dynamics.
And some of the positive parts
of it does bring new markets.
So yes, that's an ongoing
challenge and there are
ongoing struggles to
try to find ways
that they can be employed.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: Tell
me the name again.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
THERESE CAOUETTE: OK
AUDIENCE: You made this
statement already [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: OK, the
question was, what can men do?
And if men had a different
attitude, wouldn't some of
this change?
And I would say it's yes.
There's two ways.
One of the ways-- in the
beginning we focused way too
much on women and girls.
And I think what we're learning
too is that this is a
dynamic and something that
affects the whole community.
So I say it's both ways.
I think we too as organizations
have to see this
as a community issue.
And I think for men, it's
important for them to speak to
women's rights.
What's always the hardest
for me is the
girls that I work with--
especially the girls--
their self esteem is so low
that they actually believe
that it's their fault that
this has happened.
So I think promoting and
speaking to women about girls
and about women in
a positive--
I think that happens in
our day-to-day life.
One of the most disturbing
things for me is when Western
travelers go to Asia and they
are really awful tourists,
quite frankly.
It's just disrespectful.
And then even for myself as a
woman, I don't stand up to it
as much as they should.
Sometimes you should really
say something.
And I think for men to say it
to other men or at least not
to participate.
To be not other and to put
yourself in that context.
I think we all have a
lot of challenges in
how we "other" people.
And I would say that both in our
context and also when we
look abroad that's
a challenge.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: Yes.
Yes.
That's where I think we need
to grow as an organization.
What we've been trying to do in
the last few years, but we
were very slow to approach
it that way.
And if I could turn back the
time and the clock, I would
have done that much earlier.
Because I think it's
fundamental to
changing these dynamics.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: Oh
I'm sorry, yeah.
He said, wouldn't it be better
if got boys in the schools
involved in girls issues and
rights of the female child.
And to be more respectful of one
another, and I agreed and
I thought we should actually
been doing that much sooner
than we have.
Just in the last few years we
start to see these programs as
being coed for both boys and
girls, instead of pulling the
girls aside and working
on these issues
just with female children.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: To Burma.
Yeah.
Yeah one of the things that we
do, maybe might be why you
asked this question, I'm not
sure, but we do we do a lot of
very, very small grants
to community leaders--
and to repeat the
question, sorry.
What can you do to promote
strong women
role models for girls?
Is that pretty accurate?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: And what's
possible to do that in those
communities.
And one of the things that we've
been doing a lot of is
trying to do very, very small
grants to women in those
communities to take
a leadership role.
To organize girls to get
involved, to do livelihood
projects, to take
a more prominent
role in their community.
And that a lot of that
is just small grants.
We've been actually reading a
very interesting book I would
encourage you to read called
Positive Deviance.
To look at women in those
communities who are taking
small risks in their community
to do something different, to
make a difference, and
to build on that.
Not to bring it in from the
outside, or a program in from
the outside, but see what
they're doing already in those
communities.
This is a book we've been
reading in our program team
that has been very
inspirational.
We just shared parts of it with
a number of our partners
in the field and translated
into several languages.
It's a very thought-provoking
approach to development that
I'd encourage you to
take a look at.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: Yeah, they're
saving circles that
we've done.
Actually a lot of them with
people who are HIV positive
and have been ostracized
in their community.
But ways to get them organized
and to work with each other.
Not only but also with
some women's groups.
But finding they're very small
and it's actually very
difficult to do, because no big
philanthropy or donor or
even international organization
wants to give out
a $8,000 grant.
And it's very hard
to monitor that.
So to set up networks in the
communities or in the country
where that's possible.
So you give a big grant and then
that network can give out
smaller grants.
But you have to set up something
that's different
than the model we currently have
for development to make
those kind of small
differences work.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: So the
question is, how do we recover
or how do we know if people
been able to be tracked or
returned home after they've
been sent abroad.
Or after they've gone to look
for work or possibly been
trafficked.
And I would say it's incredibly
difficult.
The most that we can do
is work on both sides.
We work both on the China side
of the border and the Burma
side, the Thai side and
the Burma side.
And through those networks,
we can try to track.
But it's very, very difficult,
and we have families and
parents who have been waiting
for their kids for years.
And I just actually last week
met someone a woman who was
waiting for her husband to
return yet, She hasn't heard
from him in three years.
So she has no idea if he's gone
off on a fishing boat and
not been allowed to come back to
land, or he's been put in a
factory or he died.
She may never know.
This happens a lot, and it's
very difficult to track,
unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: She's asking
reintegrating back home and do
you see them being trafficked
again or moving again.
I think is a vicious cycle.
I think once they've gone
abroad, they come back.
It's very difficult
to return home.
There's still no jobs there.
And that's why I showed
that picture of them
praying at the shrine.
They think OK, I'll have a
good prayer and next time
hopefully I won't have such bad
luck, or I'll have better
luck and I'll try again.
And this cycle just
goes on and on.
About the thing we were talking
about at lunch just
before I came is it's also it
is very difficult for people
to get remittances to send
their money back home.
And this is one of things you're
talking about with the
new cell phone banking.
That's very exciting, because
possibly if they could remit
their money back home--
send it home safely.
Instead, now they're carrying
it all on their body.
So everybody knows they
have all the money.
They're ripped off all the time,
constantly, so they end
up back home with nothing and
then it starts all over again.
And sometimes I really believe
if we could get a safe way for
that money to get home, they
could actually start a small
business or they'd have some
capital to do something.
But because we don't have that
set up very easily-- the
banking system's so weak,
there's no banks in these
rural areas, there's not a
remittance system, and so the
cycle just keeps going
on and on again.
It's very hard to break it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: This is asking
if there's any other
development projects that are
also helping all of us deal
with this issue, like roads
or cell phones, banking.
All of it has its
pros and cons.
But I would say, one of things I
often tell people is even in
these villages, almost every
village I showed you, all of
those kids--
well, they all have access
to a cell phone.
Somebody's got a cell phone.
They don't have electricity, but
they use the solar-powered
something and they've got
access to a cell phone.
And a lot of those communities
have Gmail accounts.
Those kids give me their
Gmail accounts.
Now they have no internet,
but they know
that Gmail's out there.
And either somebody set them up
an account or somebody will
come through with a smartphone
and let them rent the access
to the smartphone for a couple
minutes or hours.
Even up in the northern Burma
with China, kids are giving me
their Gmail accounts.
So I think it's exciting and
there's opportunities.
Even with our partners,
I can GTalk with them.
Development's changed completely
since 30 years ago
when I went out to a remote area
and you'd send a telex
every month on how
things are going.
It's exciting and there's
a lot of opportunity.
At the same time, there's
also a lot of risk.
A lot of opportunities that
these young people don't know
how to evaluate or understand
or be savvy with.
They don't have the worldview
to be able to move with this
technology safely.
So it's a mix.
I think it's the same things
that are positive also have
their challenges.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: Most of
them are illiterate.
This is why Paula was mentioning
one of these things
with voice recognition.
That they're thinking of trying
to do some health care
services with voice
recognition.
That's so interesting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: Say
again one more time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: The question
is, are we working with
partners to utilize Google
Apps more effectively.
And the answer is, we're trying
to learn how to utilize
Google Apps.
I think our partners
really want it.
They're asking us
all the time.
We come from the development
world.
So a lot of this is trying to
find new partners, even in our
own organization or in the
countries also that can help
us learn and move with the
opportunities that exist.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PAULA BOCK: That was a great
question about partners.
And I just want to clarify, as
our name is Community Partners
International, we have
indigenous partners--
over 100 indigenous partners.
They're local people, and they
work with the communities to
improve health care, to
improve education.
So we call them our partners.
Are some of them
on Google Apps?
I know at least one
of them is.
And then our partners
who help us and
provide pro bono services.
For example, our website was
set up by wonderful partner
who works with Tiffany Asia.
So we need a partner to help us
do our Google Apps because
we're doing it so clumsily.
Yes, we would love that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PAULA BOCK: Oh you do?
PAULA BOCK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PAULA BOCK: OK.
PAULA BOCK: Oh wow.
Well that would be wonderful.
Thank you.
Yes.
Thanks.
THERESE CAOUETTE: I think partly
because we don't know
it so well, it's very difficult
for us to help the
people in the field think
about how to use it.
And sometimes now with all the
people coming into Burma, for
example-- but you could
talk about other
countries as well--
it's very hard to see our
partners who've worked there
in very, very difficult
circumstances for so many years.
They are being overwhelmed by
all these international
organizations who come in and
they've got the website, they
have all the resources, they
know how to use these tools.
And our partners lose their
voice because they don't know
how to enter and
engage in that.
And I think we really need some
people who have different
skill sets than we have
to work with them.
Yeah.
PAULA BOCK: [INAUDIBLE]?
THERESE CAOUETTE: So the
question was, do you see a
generation gap between the
younger generation and their
aspirations in with the parents
and the traditions.
And I would say certainly yes.
But I would say that most of
the parents still encourage
their children.
They're very proud of their
children when they go abroad
and go to work.
They're very honored, but they
don't consider all the changes
that are going to happen.
So when they come back changed
and not respecting the
traditions, then the
conflicts arise.
But they're caught, and at the
same time, if they bring home
some money and they have a new
aluminum roof and some new
things in the house,
they're very proud.
So it's a conflict, I think.
And maybe not all so different
than our own families.
But they are very proud when
their children go abroad.
That they're working in another
country, that they're
learning another language, that
they've traveled beyond.
But at the same time, when
they come home there's
terrible clashes, actually.
OK, it's time.
So anyway, thank
you very much.
It was great questions.
It was really wonderful to
be able to come here.
Thanks.